I just live life to the fullest and
without those things I find like the
most Joy like I'm not like you guys I'm
not stuck to my phone like I'm just in
the moment yeah um we don't have to go
over screen times CU we may find that
that's literally a [__] lie oh yeah
should we look at everybody's screen
time yeah yeah let's do it yeah you know
what's worse is we just came back from
Big Bear and like that's not going to
help my case like somehow I still like
we just spend a bunch of time together
but like did less yeah like no we
literally sat in the house all [__]
day like it was crazy you didn't hike
one time hell no that's that's crazy for
you I tried I tried trust I tried I was
no [__] you Tred to get us to go skiing
and that is
crazy getting a group of seven people
who have never touched a ski to be like
guys we should just go skiing like it'd
be super casual y'all don't get me and Y
will never ever understand me and that's
okay I've come to terms with that but I
am different dude all the way up we
literally like we all went in separate
cars and me and our two friends friends
in our car were like how much you want
to bet Drew is going to ask us to go
[__] skiing and the first thing he
did when we got there was like should we
go skiing and bunch of years in a row
and all of us are like no they're
bullies I'm no I understand like seeing
is hard and not for everybody and like
I'm probably the only person that can do
it so like y'all just don't want to try
and that's okay that's all right yeah
I'm better than you okay screen time
screen time and you go first are we
doing weekly average or like I'm just
doing yesterday January 15th okay janary
that's not fair f let's do daily average
okay do last week's daily average mine
is pretty bad guys good news I'm up 18%
if this was a stock market I think I'd
be in the clear but it's not I'm down
18% ironically um I am at 9 hours and 10
minutes last week so wow guys honestly
it's all the part of the research how do
you think I get up here and I kill it
come on yeah exactly yeah I got to be on
that phone 22 hours of my last week
we're spend on Tik Tok thank God yeah 6
hours not bad yeah I'm at
9:56 yo this C day that's what I was
about to say this is crazy I was doing
good I was below average most of the
week and then on January 13th I logged
13 hours and 40 minutes
bro dude there's a hole in your mind
from this day no no no no you know
what's worse is that's not his worst
screen time
ever baby [__] for Drew yeah this is I
was not cooking like this was a big flop
day 9 hours and 37 minutes on Tik Tok
there's a hole in your head dude that is
crazy that is crazy holy [__] 9 hours 37
minutes in one day in one day you logged
a shift of Tik Tok bro that's crazy yeah
now imagine if I was getting paid yeah
I'd be rich and you'd be jealous paid to
browse yeah no that's like really really
[__] up dude he he's had worse though
your your best screen time I I want to
dig through and see if I could find it
cuz I got it on video us seeing you open
it but I think one time it was like it
was like 18 hours like it was literally
like he woke up that day locked in
stayed on all day and went the [__] to
sleep yeah okay in my defense do you
skip meals and showers yes yeah I got to
log in more
I got to get higher I got to get it
higher um no I like [__] Diamond
rated Tik Tok browsing I like actually
probably am in like the world's highest
percentage they did like a Tik Tok
wrapped and I was like too scared to
look at it cuz I would have ranked like
I'm not kidding in the top 1% like it's
F Grand Master Tik Tok browser yeah
literally I'm like moving chess pieces
um no uh what was I saying um I oh I
went back to Texas and like I go back
just like two or three times a year for
like a couple weeks at a time and this
time like it was just like weird family
[__] going on so I was just like locked
in my room the whole time like on my
[__] phone and uh I literally you can
like see the
um uh like when I woke up cuz I like
went to bed at like 3:00 a.m. and then I
woke up at like 500 a.m. and stayed on
my phone all [__] day long and every
single bar was like filled with blue
like you're just flexing you're like 2
hours to sleep I can still get it done
dude yeah it was it was crazy it was it
was really [__] up and your right hand
just isn't like you don't have arthritis
from just know he holds it like an old
person you know like how like there's
that theory that our fingers are kind of
like morphing and becoming like like to
our phone like I watched him like type
like that like I'm like I'm like the I'm
like geriatric when I use my phone but I
use it like uh that take so long got so
many hours slow as [__] cuz he has to
talk into it to that's why I talk into
my phone now because if I would have
done it on here and you would have
blasted me for typing true that's
literally me that's like
me like the hands have like the bumps in
them and [__] like I literally have that
dude I was actually looking at that the
other day cuz like my pinky and my
pointer finger on this like kind of like
curve and I was like oh my God I
literally have like neander tholly and
iPhone hands like it's like so [__] up
but I'm never going to get off of it cuz
like I don't give a [__] actually why
why do they curve in from holding my
phone so like I have like that like
little divot where my phone sits ah
isn't that crazy what do you do on the
phone like you actually don't want to
know no I literally I just sit here like
wide eyed like scrolling through Tik Tok
like I'm literally like but I do like
Tik Tok tick Tik Tock deep Dives I like
I should make a career out of it for
real cuz I find CRA [__] like like the
method that y'all need to try out at
some point is like you know when Tik Tok
like will recommend you like a random
video with one like and it's just like
the most insane [__] you've ever seen um
go to the comments on that video or go
to their profile and find a comment on
one of their videos and go to their page
and just keep doing that over and over
again until you hit like this like
jackpot of like a person you don't know
exists and you should have never known
exists I can literally feel like the
fabric of space ripping when I see these
people like it's it's crazy like I it's
really really no I have seen him like he
he'll like airplan and show us this and
we have found some of the most like
jarring cases of human existence I've
like ever seen I I got one and I grew up
in Miami so that's like saying a lot
yeah I got one I'm curious to know if
you know this person like a like a
person you kind of keep up with can I
please hit my puff bar please please I'm
like actually about to freak out like I
don't know if you anybody has noticed my
hand has been right here for like 20
minutes it's really funny if we just
collectively go no that's kind of rud
ask again ask ask that's weird okay
don't look at me like look up your [__]
bro come on yeah let's see the p no no
no let's pull it up well we have to go
to the bonus right yeah all right well
we'll do this in the bonus so um oh
y'all are abusing the [__] out of us
today didn't know that yeah yeah that's
news to me oh my god well you know we we
got you on the 13k and the oh true true
we got
H and my cold sandwich I'm not kidding
if you did give me a per if you gave me
a bottle of perks for real I'm going to
wrap one in a blunt and smoke it are
cooked the fact that you're both like
are these actually perk 30s you guys are
fried dude no okay we were talking about
this so my home girl got really sick and
she got given coding and me and Drew
were like actually like dude should we
like go get some from she like she took
us so serious she HIIT us up and she's
like hey I'm done using it like for like
medical reasons I have half a bottle
left if if you want it I mean were like
my God and we were like damn dude like
if people knew like the kind of stuff we
like talk about behind doors they'd
actually think we are Tweakers yeah but
we're not in our defense we haven't had
or I haven't had an opiate since I was
13 years old no it was probably like 17
yeah um which was this year yeah which
was last year yeah um so I just have an
affinity for opiates like can I [__]
live like can I live you can't really op
I think that's the number one killer no
we got him on a clean path yeah we got
I'm good y' I'm
good